[Music]
what i'm going to do in this class is
use the lessons of history
to apply to your daily life
[Music]
that's what i love about history it can
really give you perspective solace
and give you hope
i will use examples from the four
presidents i know the best
abraham lincoln teddy roosevelt franklin
roosevelt and lyndon johnson
each one of these presidents was a
leader during a time
of great crisis we can learn from their
failures
and their ability to acknowledge those
failures and learn from their mistakes
i'd love to just transport them into you
think of what you learn from parents
from people who have experience
you're learning from generations that
lived before us it makes you feel you're
part of a continuum
you're not just here alone so it makes
you a deeper person and
maybe even gives you that great thing
called wisdom
[Music]
i think about abraham lincoln he scoured
the countryside for books and he read
everything he could lay his hands on he
understood that he was a work in
progress
nobody's going to be perfect the most
important thing for
a leader to develop is the ability to
grow all of us in our lives are going to
suffer difficult times
and the question is can you get through
it can you grow through it can you learn
from it
i'm doris kearns-goodwin and this is my
master class
[Music]
[Music]
you